el primer escándalo que estalló para
boris johnson llegó apenas unos meses
después de su aplastante victoria
electoral en 2019 en abril de 2020 el
nuevo primer ministro y su pareja
decidieron renovar su residencia privada
un donante toribio al partido
conservador más de 50 mil libras para
las obras una donación que debería
haberse hecho pública pero nunca fue así
más tarde johnson afirmó haber pagado el
mismo la factura la investigación
absolvió a johnson de cualquier
infracción pero le criticó duramente por
no haber revelado información clave pero
el escándalo que hizo saltar a los
medios de comunicación se produciría en
medio del primer confinamiento por
coronavirus en el reino unido- con la
pandemia fuera de control se reveló que
el asesor especial de boris johnson
dominique camins viajó cientos de
kilómetros al norte de su vivienda de
londres para pasar tiempo en una casa de
campo familiar con su esposa e hijo a
pesar de mostrar síntomas de kobe 19
después realizó una excursión de un día
a la cercana localidad de barnard caso
para según dijo poner a prueba su vista
comments negó haber infringido las
normas del confinamiento que boris
johnson se tomó con su pareja barbie
simons en el caribe durante la navidad
de 2019 las vacaciones las pagó el dueño
de una cadena de tiendas de telefonía
móvil pero su donación nunca se hizo
pública el siguiente escándalo que
golpeó al gobierno llegó en noviembre
del año pasado se descubrió que el
diputado conservador owen paterson había
infringido las normas sobre grupos de
presión al plantear cuestiones en el
parlamento en nombre de empresas
privadas una comisión parlamentaria
recomendó suspender lo durante 30 días
pero por primera vez en décadas los
legisladores encabezados por los
diputados tories desestimaron la
recomendación del comité de normas
votando en contra de la suspensión
boris johnson ha sobrevivido hasta ahora
pero podrían las últimas acusaciones
sobre fiestas con alcohol en el número
10 de downing street durante el primer
confinamiento por comí 19 ser el último
clavo en el ataúd del liderazgo de
johnson el premier siempre ha negado
haber infringido a sabiendas las normas
del confinamiento pero a medida que se
revelan nuevos encuentros festivos
mientras los británicos estaban
obligatoriamente aislados crecen las
voces que exigen su renuncia nadie sabe
cuánto tiempo más el primer ministro
podrá aferrarse a su trabajo